我用严谨君二的风格做了一部青春片
风格提示词都整理好了
又是一年夏天
青春的告别从不是一句
再见
是回头才发现
喜欢的那个人你从来没说过
今天我们来拆解影像美学大师
严谨君二的镜头
专门拍这种没说出口的青春
他的镜头拼爱自然光
柔和的色调与空静留白
天空 田野 细腻的颗粒感
丁达尔光笑成为其标志性视觉符号
他慎常用回忆 书信 旁白
构建非线性叙事
聚焦青春的纯粹与遗憾
情感表达克制而内面
留白处更显张力
在眼前老师的镜头里
青春从来不靠台词
今天我们从构图 光线 调色
这三个底层逻辑入手
重新复刻那一秒的心动
在构图上没有繁复的背景描述
人物头顶是天空
是远山
是整片未发生的留白
少才是对情绪的尊重
第二是给光线赋予重量
大量的逆光从主体后方打来
光圈 蕴染 自然溢出
这正是梦幻感的来源
默认的应光逻辑必须被对冲
最后是色调的锚定情绪
青春就是米黄 木蓝 淡青 浅白
这种低饱和褪色胶片
再施以青色的压制
把高饱和的塑料杆压成呼吸时间
这种清浅就是眼睛俱二风格的最强密码
镜头之外是叙事的呼吸
用慢镜 长镜 手持微晃
让时间更慢
小巷 校园 雨天
这些最日常的布景
反而是情绪最浓的容器
牛白不必多言
松陷时空的交错便是回望本身
希望你以后能用它
情绪的底色是克制的涌动
暗恋不必说出口
遗憾不必给结果
一个回眸一片光斑
爱与难过全藏其中
温柔比热烈更难忘
伤感的
从来不是失去
是未曾发生
这种没说出口的青春
便也变成了无声的心动
在遗憾中成长
也是青春最值得纪念的事情
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive